[Música]
estoy súper contento de estar aquí
ciudad victoria que chido neta me hace
muy feliz poder estar aquí con ustedes y
con theft cuando me dijeron oye este hay
opción de dar una plática te dije ah qué
chido claro me encanta la idea puedo
hablar de algunos de mis libros de las
conferencias que suelo dar puedo hablar
de lo que siempre hablo en lo cual me
siento muy cómodo pero decidí hacer algo
diferente y dije voy a hablar de algo
que no domine algo nuevo para porque la
vida es corta y hay que hacer cosas
diferentes
y cuando pensé en hacer algo nuevo
dije que miedito no porque pues no
controlo no me la cee no he dado esa
misma presentación y entonces dije bueno
de todas formas con ese miedo de todas
formas me voy a aventar voy a hacer algo
aunque me dé miedo es más voy a platicar
de eso voy a platicar de como el miedo a
mí me ha ayudado a cambiar mi vida me ha
ayudado a encontrar mi pasión
entonces vas a decirle pero como no
la cuestión aquí es que cuando cada vez
que yo tengo que hacer algún cambio en
mi vida el miedo me ha ayudado cuando me
he mudado de ciudad cuando he iniciado
un negocio o cuando he terminado un
negocio o si es cuando de verdad sientes
miedo porque el qué dirán y todo es muy
fuerte pero entonces a mí el miedo me ha
ayudado
de dos formas muy contundentemente de
forma que hasta inclusive considero que
el miedo pues es mi amigo porque todo el
mundo vamos a sentir miedo toda la vida
y entonces aquí la cuestión es que una
de las cosas que hace que a mí el miedo
me caiga bien es porque uno me ha
ayudado a poder decidir qué hacer me
toma mucho tiempo a veces hacer cosas
sencillas pero cuando tengo que hacer
algo más contundente
luego más rápido porque porque el miedo
me guía a tomar decisiones casi casi
cuando yo siento miedo de las opciones
que tengo en la que más miedo siento es
a donde me aviento entonces una u otra
forma que me ha ayudado también el miedo
es que ya que estoy haciendo las cosas
ya que me metí en ese problema pues no
conoces en dónde estás metido no una
nueva empresa una nueva ciudad y
entonces dices que miedito no que de
pronto me quedé sin dinero que medito
pero entonces el miedo en lugar de hacer
que te aplastan es en lugar de hacer que
te quedes en tu camisa sin salir a mí el
miedo me activa me hace activarme
y entonces cuando ya pasa esto de que ya
sé qué decisiones debo de tomar por el
miedo
pues ya lo que sigue después es tomar
acción ya tengo miedo no quiero terminar
vendiendo mi cuerpo cambiando sexo con
señores a cambio de comida o algo así
así que me voy a activar y me voy a
poner a chambear
cuando les conté a mis hijos cuando salí
de mi propia empresa como que les vi las
caritas de ay ay ay enserio papá te
saliste de tu propia empresa y dije sí
pero me preocupa mucho su psicología así
que los lleve al psicólogo no dije oye
quiero saber cómo están mis hijos cómo
están tomando esto de que me salí de mi
propia empresa no y pasó algo muy loco
porque mi hijo hizo un dibujo de una
silla y salía yo con él agarrados de la
mano
y entonces la psicóloga le dijo oye y
esto que que anda con la silla o qué es
esto niño y lo que le dijo él fue algo
que me marcó para toda la vida y me dio
cuenta me hizo darme cuenta de qué tipo
de persona soy ahorita les voy a contar
más de esta parte pero el caso es que
ellos mis hijos les quedó claro que su
papá se dedica a lo que realmente le
apasiona eso es algo que les he podido
transmitir toda la vida
aquí la cuestión es que todos dicen
bueno pero qué es eso de que te dedicas
en lo que te apasiona y entonces hay
algo que me gusta explicar a la gente de
qué es esto de que la gente quiere
dedicarse a lo que les apasiona qué es
eso cuando la gente me pregunta oye cómo
le hago para encontrar mi pasión no sé
cuál es mi pasión le digo no importa no
te preocupes porque la gente busca su
pasión como si estuviera buscando sus
lentes o las llaves o el control remoto
y no es así realmente lo que somos son
unos unos mamíferos lampiños muy lindos
sobreviviendo alimentándonos en un
planeta que es una esfera dando vueltas
quién sabe dónde y lo que se trata
básicamente sé que sobrevivamos no
necesitas tener una súper pasión
cumplida sobrevive carnal gones solar
más pero para sobrevivir
necesitas alimentarte para poder
alimentarse
obviamente necesitas obtener dinero
porque si no no puedes comprar la comida
y para eso necesitas trabajar necesitas
hacer algo a cambio cierto y
si tú en ese trabajo lo disfrutas y
dices no manches mi pasión este sismo
verdadero mole a ok eso es un lujo pero
de lo que se trata es de que comas
porque eres un mamífero nada más
entonces ya cuando tienes una chamba que
tienes un oficio inmediatamente lo que
la gente hace es oye ya tengo que comer
ya tengo el oficio pero enseguida viene
el aburrimiento y dices quiero hacer
algo que me apasione y entonces ok
quieres alimentarte pero también que te
apasione va que es esa famosa pasión
cómo encontrarlo
y yo digo no lo encuentres no busques tu
pasión como si fueran los lentes si no
tienes que hacer muchas cosas tienes que
hacer proyectos tienes que asegurarte de
que hagas las suficientes cosas en tu
vida como para que de ahí te des cuenta
de que te gustó para qué eres bueno para
qué tienes talento en dónde está el bar
o quién piensa que eres bueno para esto
y cómo te sientes haciendo esto tienes
que hacer muchas cosas entonces la gente
me dice algo así como me estás diciendo
que debo andar dando tumbos tengo que
andar de chamba en chamba para ver qué
es lo que me gustó yo les digo bueno
pues si otra de las opciones que puedes
hacer es quedarte haciendo lo mismo en
tu chamba que ni te gusta y que 50 años
después digas qué hubiera pasado si
hubiera emprendido qué hubiera pasado si
hubiera hecho esto o lo otro y te haces
de esos viejitos amargados que no les
gusta nada de lo que hacen los niños y
que andan quejándose de todo no yo
prefiero hacer un viejito feliz
y lo curioso aquí es que cuando tú te
pones a chambear en algo que te gusta
puedes cambiar los fines de semana
puedes cambiar en las noches puedes
cambiar todo el tiempo y no lo ves como
algo que te agobia te pones a chambear
super rudo y paradójicamente cuando te
echan veas mucho haces calidad cuando
haces calidad vendes y cuando vendes
haces billete así que si lo que quieres
es hacer billete deja de pensar en el
billete y haz algo que de verdad te
guste porque va a terminar haciendo
mucho billete va a venir el billete a ti
por el hecho de que tú estás contento
haciendo todo lo que haces y lo
disfrutas
cuando eres niño siempre te preguntan
qué vas a hacer cuando seas ni cuando
seas grande me dices como pues no sé la
gente responde diferentes cosas yo
cambiaría la pregunta yo no diría que
vas a ser cuando seas grande sino que
vas a hacer cuando seas grande porque
qué vas a hacer un mamífero eso es
forzoso qué es lo que vas a hacer muchas
cosas mamá quiero hacer muchas cosas que
tengo que decidir una sola cosa no eres
alguien fijo no sé qué estudias doctor
eres doctor estudio arquitecto soy
arquitecto no eres eso no eres un doctor
no eres un arquitecto no eres un
licenciado eres un mamífero y como
mamífero puedes hacer todo lo que
quieras porque la vida es corta debe
hacer algo chido que te haga sentir
orgulloso yo particularmente he cambiado
mi vida radicalmente por lo menos cinco
veces muy rudo porque ha pasado muchas
más veces no pero cinco es con las que
sí me acuerdo que dije ay ay ay y que me
dio mucho miedo dicho sea de paso verdad
la primera fue cuando me fui a vivir
dejé una chamba bien chida bien pagada
bien cómoda vendí mi harley davidson
boom vale a españa
cuál fue el resultado de haber llegado
que ni siquiera tenía un plan y llegué a
pedir chamba a tocar puerta terminé
trabajando en un estudio de animación
muy reconocido y tuve de cliente a
guillermo del toro hay claramente se ve
como me la tiraba después y después la
segunda vez fue cuando dejé mi propia
empresa y mi hija tenía seis meses de
edad y yo lo dejé todo para ser un papá
chido para enseñarles como su papá se
avienta las cosas porque los retos me
prenden cuál fue el resultado de eso
que funde el estudio de animación más
reconocido del país en cuanto a
comerciales de televisión se refiere y
luego funde junto con mis socios 15
empresas aprendí muchísimo por haberme
aventado a renunciar de lo ya conocido
al abismo
la tercera vez fue cuando me salí de esa
empresa de mi propia empresa once años
después dije bye bye voy a hacer otras
cosas porque hay que sentir la
intensidad de la vida y por muchas
razones no
cuál fue el resultado de ese miedo que
hice la comunidad de medios creativos
más grande del país que son 50.000
creativos consiguiéndose chamba gracias
a mi plataforma eso me hizo sentir súper
chido de que estaba haciendo algo que
valía la pena con mi vida
la cuarta vez fue cuando volví a dejar
todo y me fui al gabacho me fui a
estados unidos y se convirtió en un año
porque fui a ver qué onda con lo del
emprendimiento de que silicon valley que
allá es la onda del san francisco
california va a doblar el cáncer que
para hacérselos rápido terminé
quedándome un año y aprendí muchísimo
del emprendimiento pero también ahora la
versión güera ya no nada más lo de
mexico y entonces después de eso como
que agarre más power y cada vez me
atreví a hacer más cosas y la quinta vez
que le quiero que les quiero contar fue
cuando ya regresé a méxico con mucho
aprendizaje y tal y dije otra vez adiós
al fin solo tengo 41 años y al fin tengo
solo dos hijos que tienen la pésima
costumbre de comer tres veces al día de
todas formas dije me voy a activar
porque a mí el miedo me sirve para
activar me y para hacer cosas
y eso el cual fue el resultado que se
puede decir que encontré mi pasión
encontré a lo que yo quiero dedicarme
100% que es hacer mi propio contenido
lo que hice fue juntar todas mis cosas
que he hecho todos mis riesgos todos mis
metas todos mis problemas todo mi
sufrimiento y todo eso y lo puse en
metodologías y en libros y en
conferencias en donde yo básicamente me
dedico a decirle a la gente que hagan lo
que realmente les gusta y entonces esa
fue mi pasión
el transmitirle a la gente lo que yo
mismo había aprendido de haberme
aventado tantas veces al riesgo
y nunca vas a conocer para que eres
bueno y en dónde está el bar o cuál que
tienes talento que te gusta
si no lo haces de a tiro al cien
aventando te no desde la comodidad de
ahí de pronto nada más voy a agarrar mi
telefonito ya ver qué puedo aprender
nuevo no aviéntate arriésgate
aquí la cuestión es consideren ustedes
qué están haciendo ustedes que los esté
poniendo en riesgo que los haga que
estén aprendiendo algo que es lo que
ustedes están tomando decisiones
radicales como para que digan oye tantas
decisiones algo me va a llevar cuando la
gente quiere hacer cambios radicales
para hacer una empresa lo que sea
piensan que puede ir bien con mi
changarro me puede ir mal
yo diría cuánto vas a aprender tienes
que juzgar todo y tienes que tener en
cuenta que lo que hagas es por en
búsqueda del aprendizaje mientras más
aprendas más vas a hacer dinero más
fácil después para eso tienes que
aventar te a lo desconocido meterte en
lugares que no conoces como yo hoy aquí
dando esta plática que no le había dado
antes pero estoy aquí ya esto se va a
convertir en un reto es lo desconocido
y hay que aventarse entonces alguien
diría pero como aventarse hablaban de ok
guay no me vengas con esas cosas de
aventarse que miedo claro el miedo es lo
que nos hace no hacer las cosas pero qué
es eso del miedo es una emoción muy
linda que nos ayuda a saber cuándo
tenemos que huir cuando tenemos que
atacar es algo que viene en nosotros
desde que desde lo más básico de
nuestros seres de la evolución desde
nuestro cerebro reptiliano y como
mamíferos lo tenemos bien activo pero
aquí la cosa es que muchas veces la
gente bueno todos incluyéndome tenemos
miedo de mil cosas que nunca van a pasar
todo el tiempo estamos en aquí la loca
de la azotea todo el tiempo nos está
diciendo no hagas ese güey te puede
pasar esto oye pero qué tal si pasa esto
qué tal si tiembla buscando en el df no
todos están así de qué tal si tiembla
wey para que tiemble el planeta vas a
estar todo el miedo ya contento que te
dé miedo cuando tiemble wey entonces que
decir que el 90 de las del 90% de las
cosas que siempre temí nunca sucedieron
eso le escuché a alguien decir
es que no me acordaba de quién era
entonces de alguien a ella que reclame
su crédito
prendes aquí las cuestiones importantes
no puedes confiar en tu mente
no puedes confiar en que lo que tú
tienes miedo es real
he visto en mis talleres etcétera cuatro
pretextos que la gente suele tener por
las razones por las que no se avienta a
buscar su pasión a hacer cosas nuevas
la primera es es que ya es demasiado
tarde ya estoy medio viejillo ya pasó
tiempo no que flojera y yo lo que le
digo es siempre puedes hacer las cosas
mcdonald's y kentucky fried chicken y
mil otras cosas súper grandes la
empezaron gente que ya tenían más de 50
o 60 años así que no hay pretexto para
empezar si hace diez años hubieras
empezado a hacer lo que quieres hacer de
verdad ahorita ya serías un experto y en
diez años te va a volver a pasar lo
mismo
roy que wii hace diez años hubiera
empezado ahorita ser experto siempre así
que siempre lo puedes hacer la segunda
es tienen miedo al éxito hay gente que
me dice no hago ya sabes que este no
quiero hacer eso en las redes sociales y
mostrarme porque no quiero ser famoso en
mi vida les respondo nunca vas a ser
famoso aunque quieras ser famoso así
nunca vas a ser famoso así que a
chambear le la tercera es que tengo
miedo al fracaso eso es más normal lo
que hay miedo al fracaso el fracaso no
existe toda persona que tenga éxito es
porque está cimentado en fracasos
los fracasos te van a llevar a algo es
información el fracaso es bueno porque
es pura información
la cuarta es el qué dirán y es como de
que llegas a la navidad y dices oiga en
la próxima navidad yo traigo el pavo y
las champañas porque voy a emprender un
negocio y resulta que pasa un año
después y llegas con un pollo rostizado
y un six que ya le falta una chela
porque te la tomaste en el camino y
tienes que saber que aunque le digas a
toda la familia que fracasaste que no te
importe no importa fracasar además de
todas formas en 100 años todos van a
estar muertos así que si te importa la
opinión de alguien es de un futuro
cadáver
y tienes que ser valiente que ser
valiente alguien que no tiene miedo no
alguien que tiene miedo y aún así se
avienta
entonces aquí la cuestión es que cuando
haces muchas cosas que eran un riesgo
generas un músculo emprendedor y te
sientes orgulloso de ti mismo porque te
aventaste a hacer las cosas y la gente
dice oye mientras más dinero tengo más
seguro voy a estar no es cierto y si no
pregúntale a los millonetas y famosos
que se andan suicidando cada media hora
aunque tienen todo el dinero del mundo
hay algo que te da más
felicidad confianza seguridad que es la
confianza en ti mismo y no el dinero el
haber pasado retos eso se da confianza
el dinero no así que tienes que estar
bien de tu mente y ser alguien que está
de acuerdo contigo mismo y que te gustas
y que sabes que la vida es corta para
que también test
y aquí la cuestión es hay que escoger lo
difícil porque ahí es en donde puede
estar más seguridad más confianza y
curiosamente más dinero también
no hay que paralizarse hay que activarse
y entonces aquí es cuando tienes que
abrazar al miedo es las cosas que
te dan miedo para que genere ese músculo
entonces les voy a contar lo que dijo mi
hijo cuando hizo la silla con mi papá y
a mí a mi papá le ofrecieron ser
presidente y él renunció para pasar
tiempo conmigo
eso me siembro me di cuenta lo que le
estoy enseñando de valor a mis hijos a
que se avienten así que a todos ustedes
les deseo mucho miedo
porque ese miedo los va a hacer
activarse y van a hacer cosas inspirar a
los demás así que les deseo que de
verdad hagan cosas increíbles para que
sean unos viejitos felices orgullosos de
sí mismos y que puedan decirle a todo el
mundo como lo hicieron muchas gracias a
todos y va a vivir vivo
[Aplausos]
[Música]